do you think i mean everything kind of
gets wrapped up in a lovely bow but do
you think there could be space for more
fierce street something in the future
100
i think that the thing that like really
drew me when i started talking about
this was that we had the opportunity
here to kind of
create our own little horror marvel
universe um
so for sure i think there's lots of
opportunity to keep kind of expanding it
and
evil still exists so is there something
in the works
or i don't know is that
how do we end this you have to go back
to where it all started
1666. there's a really fun whodunit
element that comes into play
i would love to know your reaction when
you read or found out the ending
and the big twist the good is evil i was
shocked and like i remember reading that
for the first time and just
having to like go back to certain scenes
and reread it knowing what
what i now knew and um i'm just really
happy that it translated on screen so
well
and that it's just so satisfying after
you know
all the all the um the first two movies
and all the
gruesome deaths and all the mystery just
kind of like finally put the pieces
together and it's
yeah very satisfying to watch there's
the idea behind it and the way she
handled it and
the the idea behind it i i was
almost relieved like this is exactly
where the story needs to go
like i think after it happens there's
something so satisfying about it because
of of course of of course
that's who's responsible and um and then
there's how she did it which
is something else entirely like i
watched the third film last night and
and seeing that moment when when dina
and sam
like when their love actually transcends
like actually heals sam
before uh the curse is broken that
actually
like the idea that like love between
people can
can can heal as well but
i found it i get i find it moving now
thinking about it i think that's uh
lee's treatment of that's of that is
what makes this special and takes it out
of this just
simple idea yeah it was just
i mean it's genius really even the fact
that his name is nick good
and good is evil it's just yeah you know
it's just so powerful
like you know sometimes it's the people
that are in certain positions that we
you know might think are good and then
they actually end up doing the most harm
it's just it's so deep
you know i feel like it was just so
genius and and
yeah and so clever and the fact that it
played out over three movies so where
you're really building up
like what's happening what's going on
and then at the last one it's like
yeah yeah and i don't think that people
will see it coming
no i really don't but yeah i love that
moment because it kind of clicks and
you are like oh you realize that you've
been watching these really
really like deep and and wonderful and
scary horror movies and then you realize
that it's all been like a real
allegory for real life and the things
that have happened throughout history
and
oppressions that have happened
throughout history and um i think it's
so clever and so smart
and i think the fact that it's back to
back to back it'll be to a point where
people won't have
enough time to even like put it together
and then they'll be like oh my god
yeah exactly they don't have enough time
to like stew on it and figure it out on
their own yeah yeah
it's been fun to talk to people who have
seen them and be like what do you think
after the first one and they're like oh
i don't know like i'm excited to see
what the witch looks like and i'm like
it's not a witch like it's a man
a human man and he's the sheriff
[Music]
so